before we begin we'd like to say that in
our opinion it is not suitable for
children
or for those of you who may have a
nervous disposition
hello and welcome to this very special
live episode of trigonometry i'm frances
foster i'm constant and kitten and this
is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people
i don't think it gets any more
fascinating than the two people we have
for you today you know them all
evolutionary biologist dr heather heing
and of course dr
jordan b peterson we're going to bring
them in in a second before we do i
should just tell you very quickly the
format of our conversation today
we're going to talk for about an hour to
an hour and 15 minutes it'll be
us in conversation with jordan and
heather then we're gonna have a quick
break and then we're gonna take
all your questions if you want to submit
a question uh for us to put to
either of our guests or for us to
discuss as a group uh there's a paypal
link below
in the description of the video or you
can just send a super chat our team here
will collate
everything and then we'll ask the most
suitable and the best questions
about an hour and 15 minutes from now so
frances i think without any further ado
we should get started
couldn't agree more our first guest is
evolutionary biologist dr heather heing
welcome to trigonometry
thank you so much guys i'm thrilled to
be here
and our next guest is dr jordan peterson
welcome to trigonometry welcome back
good to see you again
it's great to have you back listen let
us get started
straight away uh there's an issue that
we've been talking about on the show
a long uh for about for a long time it's
something that is really become very
important
um we talk about identity politics but
there's a deeper thing
that's going on let me summarize it very
as
briefly as i can the idea is at some
point 50 to 60
years ago something happened where
increasingly you started to see
an increase in fatherlessness increasing
breakdown of the family as people
describe it
and many people including one of our
former guests mary eberstad
argued there was a sexual revolution
that triggered that others have other
theories but
nonetheless many people say the product
of all of the
of that has been uh the the focus
on on identity the the breakdown of the
family has resulted in many of the
things that we're seeing
now identity politics uh obsession with
finding your own community that's not
really about your family because you
don't really
feel attached to yours to the one that
you have etc
uh heather it's your first time on the
show it's such a pleasure
tell us what do you make of all of that
as i look at is your cat
flicking its ear to my long question uh
what what what do you make of all of
that
and uh what are your thoughts on on that
uh issue
oh there's about eight different topics
and what you asked right um
since you raised uh the the cat who's
partially visible on camera here
cats are of course sexually reproducing
organisms
as all mammals are as all vertebrates
are with a couple
a handful of exceptions but cats don't
really have fathers
i mean they do at the genetic level but
they don't at the social behavioral
level the way that humans do
and so you know there's there's an
ongoing live
question as to exactly how monogamous
humans really are
and in poliginous cultures children
don't know their fathers as much
it's at least a different kind of
relationship but the cultures that we
are
we are living in are at least monogamous
by expectation
uh and you know that doesn't that
doesn't suggest that there isn't a whole
lot of cheating that goes on of course
but you know what is what does it mean
to have a father then what does it mean
for me to say for instance that this cat
doesn't have a father you know he had a
relationship with a mother
who who nursed him and who taught him
some things about being a cat
and then they probably never met again
whereas in humans the relationship with
both parents
is critical for most uh to
emerge into adulthood as you know as
as able humans regardless of what sex we
are
so you know was it
was it the loss of fathers in
in the family the breakdown of the
nuclear family that contributed to
identity politics
that's not one of the things that i tend
to point to but i think it's certainly
contributed
um i i often go a little bit more
recently as you know 30 years ago ish
we start to have this perfect storm of
um
of postmodernism in academia gaining
ground
of uh of legal drugs being shoved at
children and it's different ones for
girls and boys because we see different
uh so-called failings in boys and girls
it's
it's the screens it's the helicopter
parenting
but you know add into that mix having
only one parent
uh in a household so that you don't have
the tension the
back and forth the ability for two
parents to actually both have their eyes
on a problem
you know be it a behavior that a child's
engaging in or
you know whatever else and discuss it um
yeah that's
that's going to make things much harder
for for children growing up
i'm curious jordan yeah sorry heather
jordan
what about you you've talked about the
sexual revolution and its impact in the
past what do you make of all of this
well i think there are two questions
that
are sort of importantly nested in your
question and one is
the issue of identity per se and why
that's become
a question and then the second question
is
why has identity politics arisen as an
answer to that question i would say the
first
issue has arisen because of
technological transformation
in large part and you could say that
reproductive technology and its
consequent effects on the family would
be one branch of that
but look if you look at more traditional
societies and so let's say those are
societies that aren't transforming
technologically at the same rate that
the world is transforming now the issue
of identity doesn't come up
that much because there isn't much
choice
you do what your parents did if you're a
man you do what your father did if
you're a woman you do what your mother
did
and it the question doesn't arise
because the options aren't there
well now we have options
and we don't know how many there are
what the limits are and we don't even
know what the options are to
to some degree because things change so
quick we can't even keep up with them
i i can't keep up with my computer
i mean it's so interesting well and and
distressing in some sense and this is
partly a function of age
i'm surrounded by gadgets i don't
understand
that are changing faster than i can
adapt to that are smarter than me
and that's just one and and i'm actually
fairly technologically astute you know
like i
mastered computers well to some degree
at least i could use them
when i was in my 30s and you know i was
sort of on the edge of i would say the
generation that managed that at least to
some degree
but the issue of identity comes up when
the pathway isn't
fixed well it's not fixed okay so then
then see nietzsche said at one point
that the issue of morality
per se the question of what is moral
doesn't emerge until you compare many
moralities
it doesn't emerge as a question the
question before that is what's right and
wrong within a given moral system
not is there morality as such that only
comes up when the
when the idea becomes questionable well
now we have this problem
what is identity well and then because
no one knows the answer to that off the
top of their heads and has never
generated an
articulated uh and lengthy thought
through response to that someone can say
well
it's your felt sense of gender
it's like well oh maybe
no actually that's a very small
subset of what of what it is it's that's
a very sparse theory
but you know your theory of a helicopter
is sparse
and so you know what i mean if i asked
you to draw a helicopter you'd draw
something like a four-year-old would
produce because what the hell do you
know about helicopters and
if you think identity is less complex
than helicopter well
you're wrong and so you know the the
issue comes up because we have so many
paths to choose from and then
these political answers come up and no
one knows what to do with them exactly
because
no one can articulate the rationale for
the traditional modes of being
that's not easy you know like that's
that's hard
is the family a patriarchal structure
well
i don't know maybe well no upon
consideration over many years here's a
counter argument but it's not like you
can just
generate that on the fly and so you know
we fall prey to these
casual critiques in some sense but
they're less casual than our ability to
articulate our
you know implicit beliefs and so we get
caught out all the time
technological transformation makes us
uncertain of who we are
and partly by providing us with more
freedom and then answers arise to the
questions that are driven by that
and we we have a hard time making
philosophical sense of them or defending
ourselves against them
you know i i've been trying to think
through this idea that
human social institutions are
fundamentally predicated on the
arbitrary expression of power
it's like well yeah
sort of but wait no no
fundamentally that's wrong but it's not
like it's simple to think through and we
can return to that later
before before francis moves on to to the
next little bit
i was going to ask you is the family a
patriarchal structure
i don't see it that way and there are
there are compelling arguments in
evolutionary biology space
as to you know how it is that
males wield power uh in the outside
world
more often in a nuclear family situation
than females do uh but there's you know
there's a question then
of what your definition of power is you
know this this will seem like we quickly
fall
into a semantic trap but it's you know
if you're going to argue
you know patriarchy archi is about power
that that is what
you know patriarchal refers to so you
have to define power and
if women tend to have power within the
family within
social systems women tend to engage in
hierarchies in which the competition is
more covert
men tend to engage in competition and
hierarchies
that are more that's more overt and so
you know that is the power that is more
overt
more overt of course it is if so factor
right you can point to it and say well
that's where the power is
but the power that women tend to yield
being more cryptic being more covert and
you know
as that's partially because we are
sexually that i'm
sexually dimorphic we do have some
history of at least you know some
history of polygamy in our past such
that men
are on average bigger and stronger in
all of this and so
in engagement between the sexes women
aren't going to use
power aren't going to use physical power
that wouldn't make any sense that would
be a losing move
and so once that once you start down
that road
where women are going to be more likely
to
be able to compete on something like an
even
playing field if they're going to be
using psychological or social tools as
opposed to physical tools
when engaging with men then also you
expect and we see this is
there's plenty of evidence in the
psychological literature
as to you know the kinds of competition
that women engage in being
being more covert so all of that is sort
of a background answer to
you know it is the system we live in
patriarchal
uh only if the only kind of power you're
interested in is the overt
expressions of power especially raw
physical power well it's also
it's also whether or not you think that
the fundamental principle that
structures
social organizations is in fact the
expression of power
and it's not that's just wrong i believe
i think it's
antithetically that's the truth what do
you think it is
well if you look even at primates like
chimps
and chimps are a lot more violent the
males are a lot more violent than human
males at least reactively
and and their structure and their social
structures are more vicious and violent
than human social structures
um the alpha male so to speak that the
top
chimp is constantly engaged in grooming
and reconciliation
and in stable chimp societies attends
to the needs of the females and the
infants to a large degree
and so what dewalt has demonstrated
quite nicely
is that even among chimpanzees social
structures predicated on the arbitrary
expression of power
which we could define as the use of
force to compel
others to act against their wishes let's
say against their intrinsic desires
produces very unstable social
hierarchies that are
ripe for revolution and the chimps that
rule for a long time
are markedly cooperative now they're
still
capable of exerting force but force
isn't the animating principle of the
society which is the claim
that you know that social relations
among humans are
predicated on power that's the claim
unless we weasel out of the definition
of power
no power is when i get you to do
something you don't want to do or
else and that's that's not the basis for
human social institutions it's an
aberration and people who use
power to meet to obtain and maintain
their positions are by and large
incompetent
i think i think that's that's exactly
right and um just exactly as you say
alpha alpha males are not roots in
non-human primates
and in human primates where the systems
are functional
uh there may be other males who are
brutes but it's not the alpha alphas use
affiliative behaviors and conciliatory
behaviors and cooperation
to to accrue loyalty which then
is a way of of maintaining power
and you know that's that's only sort of
in male hierarchy space and of course
you know what's
what i think one of the modern problems
that we are experiencing
is male hierarchies and female
hierarchies
both exist they follow different rules
there are different rules of engagement
it's a very rare species that actually
has both because typically
in other species one or the other sex
disperses and you don't and and you also
don't have
multiple males and multiple females in a
group together baboons being an
interesting
uh exception to that but for us
we've combined you know we we now live
in this
attempting to be egalitarian world where
we've got
this you know call it six million years
since we split with the ancestors of
bonobos and chimps
six million years of evolution within
our particular lineage
in which we've got female hierarchical
relationships and male hierarchical
relationships and now
i don't know post-industrial something
since at least agriculture
so at the at a minute at a maximum 10
000 years old
we're combining these two hierarchies
and we're pretending it's just going to
be easy and fine
and we have to figure it out like we
have to figure out how to work together
but uh imagining that we're just going
to default into male style of hierarchy
and it's going to be cool with all the
women or that we're going to just
default into female style of hierarchy
and it's going to be cool with all the
men is an amazing error and in fact what
i feel like we see is this like pendulum
swing from well
we were just doing it the male way
because women came into sort of the
external realizations of power later
and that wasn't really working for
everyone and
at the moment we're seeing this pendulum
swing over into
really female styles of dominance
relationship
and it's equally dysfunctional it's just
something we don't have as much history
with recognizing
but that doesn't make it any better you
know this
no the yeah is all of us
that's a very controversial thing to say
especially nowadays heather
right but don't you think part of this
problem and and i'll direct this
question first at jordan
is that we now think that we are above
animals
we think that we are evolved that we are
higher superior more intelligent but
isn't that one of our main failings
not acknowledging the fact that we are
part of the animal world
well i think you're
it's very useful to inform your ideas
about what constitutes human beings by
looking at carefully controlled
experiments on animals and observations
of
animals because well if you look at our
morphology our physiology
i mean we share organs pretty much all
the way down the vertebrate
chain you know there's a lot about us
that's like other creatures now you know
there's important differences too so you
look across species and you try to make
comparisons where that seems useful and
sometimes that can clue you into how
things originated so dewalt for example
who studied primarily studied
chimpanzees has looked at the
emotional basis of morality as it
emerged in
chimpanzees and and and and before that
people like yak pancep who's
brilliant animal uh rat psychologist
essentially
rat researcher researcher of rats
showed that even rats engage in fair
play when you put them together in
repeated play bouts so
if a big rat can dominate a little rat
by the expression of power which he can
do if he's about ten percent bigger
he will do that if you put them together
and they play once
but if they play repeatedly if the big
rat doesn't let the little rat
win 30 percent of the time at least the
little rat will stop
playing and the the the
proclivity for re reciprocity has been
well
documented in many mammalian species
and so we can see that our
behavioral patterns have roots that are
very deep and that's useful it helps
clarify the philosophical discussion
helps us understand ourselves better
it helps us understand that moral
behavior for example isn't
merely a consequence of rational
decision-making or
or rational inference let's say it's
it's much more deeply rooted in us than
that
and so there now having said that i
would also say there are
there are many important differences
between human beings and other animals
not least our linguistic capacity and
our incredible capacity for complex
mimicry which is
unparalleled i would say in our visual
ability there's lots of things about us
that are quite unique
but you know you you try to derive your
wisdom where you can and you're a fool
if you ignore biology and
it's a lot easier to ignore it because
it's actually difficult to study
and you have to work at it and and so
it's easier
especially now especially if you're
driven by a utopian social theory that
implies that human beings are infinitely
malleable and you want to make them
malleable in your mold of what
constitutes the ideal well then you can
ignore biology and
you know call people biological
essentialists and other such idiocy
and we see a fair bit of that
and heather what do you think do you
think by turning our back onto
on the animal world thinking that you
know that blank slateism
etc etc what we've actually done
is create a whole raft of problems for
ourselves that didn't exist before
we're out absolutely creating a whole
raft of problems for ourselves
i would um i would add to what jordan
said another i guess another way in
another way in to point out how similar
we are to many other species out there
uh the what jordan's pointing out is our
shared history our shared
phylogenetic history evolutionary
history such that we can look at
non-human primates
and see in chimps and bonobos who are
our two closest extent
relatives uh many similarities you know
ability to you know and and yet chimps
and bonobos are so
different socially you know one of one
of them bonobos tend
very much towards explicit affiliation
and
and peacemaking and one of them chimps
not as much
with the big caveat as jordan indicated
before that the alpha is
actually a conciliatory figure um and
you go farther back you know you go
into other mammals and yes because
because we all
share this sort of founding thing that
for which we are named mammary glands
that
obligates us to maternal care and that
obligates us to sociality and
relationship
and it brings in love and therefore we
get this sort of
cascading series of events wherein we
have closer relationships
then were at least obligated by anatomy
and physiology before
the evolution of of milk and lactation
but i would say that that's actually not
even the most interesting
thing that uh we can also look to birds
and our most recent common associate
with birds was some
you know reptily thing that bears no
resemblance to any extant reptile now
you know many hundreds of millions of
years ago
so birds and mammals are not all that
closely related but in some species of
birds and crows
in parrots in a variety of lineages of
birds we also find
what looks like love and long-term
relationships
and fair play and exchanging of ideas
so what is common what how is it that we
have converged between like crows
and parrots and dolphins and elephants
and wolves
and chimps and humans and i'm leaving
some things off that list but that list
is like okay social but there's a lot
more things than that that are social
long-lived generational overlap so you
can have exchange of ideas and learning
between generations
and long childhoods so that your you
know these organisms are born or hatched
depending on if they're mammals or birds
without yet fully being what they're
going to be
you know compare that to i mean any
mammal
excuse me is somewhat somewhat what we
what we call altricial which is to say
born um you know not
fully able yet to do everything it's
going to do because it's going to need
milk from its mother
but a horse within a half an hour of
being born
is able to run around and keep up with
the herd ish because if not
it's going to get eaten whereas the
more alterational you're born the more
helpless you're born the more
software you are so no we're not blank
slates
but and this is something that um that
brett and i talk about a lot and we've
actually written into
the book that we have coming out in the
chapters on childhood
and on parenthood and relationship we're
not blank slates
but we are we argue the blankest slates
of any species on the planet like when
we are born
with whatever genetics we have on board
we have the most
potential of any species on the planet
to become anything else
like our fate our fate as individuals is
less guaranteed at birth uh than
even then even for a dolphin or an
elephant or a parrot and certainly then
for a squid or a cedar or you know a
mouse
so yeah we aren't blank slates but
we have tremendous potential to become
almost anything
and that's not at odds with the pushback
that
that you guys you know all of you and i
as well are
are giving to identity politics because
that you know that i think
identity politics is a failure of um
of an understanding the the of emergence
that the whole is greater than the sum
of the parts it is a reductionist
approach
that the identity politics says uh you
know i am
white and female and middle-aged and
american
and you know overeducated and
okay all those things are true but they
don't even begin to encompass a
description of me
and i could do the same thing for any of
you or any other human being
and that's that is a reductionist sort
of metric laden
approach to an understanding of what
humans are it's an insistence
it's an insistence and it's a it's a
numeracy too
like if you can count it then it's real
and no sometimes the most important
things aren't countable
and sometimes the things that you can
count don't matter so
let's let's be our whole best selves as
opposed to reducing us to
the things that you can label i wanted
to weave a couple of the themes that
we've talked about together there
particularly technology
and with sexual dimorphism that is
inherent in us
um do you think there will come a point
where technologically we're capable
of eradicating that should we choose to
there seems to be a lot of people who'd
like to do that
sexual dimorphism yeah but to compensate
for it somehow in a way that it doesn't
manifest itself in the way that it
currently does where
one sex is stronger and therefore quote
unquote more oppressive and the other
one is you know
you know you know what i'm talking about
yeah no of course i mean i i think this
is just
just can i swear here absolutely
absolutely
this is just batshit crazy right like i
i grew up in the 70s and 80s and
all options were on the table for me and
granted i grew up
on you know the west coast of america
with parents
who you know looked at me and said okay
we weren't expecting that in a girl but
cool you want to be mathy you want to be
sportsy like
go for it you know do do those things
and
it was because we the world seemed to be
willing to abandon
those regressive gender roles that
weren't necessary anymore
without ever pretending that me being
good at math meant i wasn't a girl
right like that that's the thing that we
are emerging into now
um it's this it's this regressive
backward slide
into stereotypes that i thought we were
free of
like actually no men can't gestate or
lactate or give birth or any of that
and if you are a particularly caregiving
man who wants to be
the primary parent for your child that's
awesome
but you still don't get to breastfeed
because that's not what men
do right so like we we can get rid of
a lot of the the layer on top that
we weren't able to before and you know
there's attention as you jordan have
pointed out you know like we've got all
this freedom
and you push it too far and you get
people really really confused and unable
to make choices among
among all of the things that are that
are downstream of the freedom but
if we can just hold on to the reality at
base and then say okay
now um you know if you're a scientist
that doesn't make you
male-ish and if you're an artist that
doesn't make you female-ish
and we like we should be able to live in
that world i feel like that is the world
that we
we're creating until uh you know frankly
until sort of the 90s when
this this grip on academia that looked
post-modern and post-structuralist
was happening and then it bled out
into the schools of ed and the media and
and hollywood and big tech and every
place else
and jordan do you think the problem
comes
from the fact that we don't believe in
religion anymore
and if you don't believe in religion i
don't know who said this then you don't
believe
you people need to believe in something
and as a result what we've taken is
identity politics as a way to
belong to a group or do you think it's
far more complex than that
well there's a new testament doctrine
that you render unto caesar what is
caesar and unto god what is god's
and i actually think that's a very
astute psychological statement
and now it depends on whether or not you
believe that human beings have a
religious instinct
and i think broadly that the answer to
that
is that they do for a variety of reasons
first of all religious experiences
elicitable by biochemical means so
that's that's pretty powerful evidence
right there but
there are all sorts of religious like
experiences that we all pursue
so we feel awe to beauty we feel awe to
the ideal
we participate in like mass worship of
sports prowess we like to see
people hit the target which is the
opposite of sin which means to miss
the target we we get enraptured
by a gospel-oriented rock
performance in a stadium and we do that
with other people and it
and it fills us with enthusiasm which is
to be filled with god because
that's what enthusiasm means we
feel awe towards certain actions that
people
undertake particularly if they're
radically altruistic or radically
truthful
we we're possessed by the desire to
mimic people that we see
act out an ideal that we don't
understand
etc etc and like i've made a list of
about 50 of these things that i'm not
going to go through all of them but
so you imagine there's an instinct that
orients us towards the ideal and that
would be part of the consequence of us
having to emerge from this insufficient
biological substructure that heather was
talking about
and move towards whatever we could be we
need a vision of what that is
and i believe that vision is deeply
influenced by biological factors
reciprocity for example which would
emerge
again from the phenomena that the social
our social nature our protracted
childhood dependence etc
it's emergent property of that all that
all of that is reflective of religious
instinct so now then you might pause it
societies have to organize themselves so
that that religious
instinct is fulfilled without it
disrupting other functions or without
other functions being disrupted by it so
the religious system collapses
well it doesn't the need for it doesn't
disappear and so then what happens as
far as i can tell is just plummets down
the value hierarchy until it hits a
point where it can find some
satisfaction so
politics becomes religion and then look
out
because see you know maybe we have some
sense of an absolute idea we have the
need for an absolute ideal
and maybe you you make that abstract and
you you you view that
as god and god is distant and ineffable
and undefinable and
abstract and eternal he's not local
he's not local to your country and your
place like
like a figure like stalin or mao and
maybe if you don't have something to
project that ideal onto
something abstracted let's say and
perhaps even something communal
then it finds it it starts to
contaminate other
functions and i i believe that i think
this is where the new atheists went so
wrong
they assumed that if we just dispensed
with all that idiotic superstition
we'd all become you know avatars of
richard dawkins style logic
assuming we had the capability which we
generally don't and
i just don't see that that's true i
don't see any evidence that that's the
case i think what happens is we become
we we dispense with the catastrophic
superstition of
catholicism and end up swallowing
something
much more ungainly and horrible
jordan i i want to latch on to that
because we've been talking about
religion
and you know how we've turned our back
on religion
don't you think a lot of these crisis
has come from the fact that we
don't yet know in the west how to
address the issue of death
and you can see the way we dealt with
covid to me it seemed like a moral
crisis
it seemed like a general panic we don't
know how to address the fact that we're
mortal
and as a result of that we just seem to
be scrabbling around for anything don't
we
including identity politics well i think
there's some truth in that i mean
one of the existential facts that
compels us to ask religious questions
is the fact of death and so
and that's why i also think you can't
eradicate religion for that matter
because
what are you going to do you're going to
eradicate people's concern with death
i don't think so you know and i've been
at funerals and
people stand around and they don't know
what sage to each other
not really maybe they can give each
other a hug that's something isn't it
but they don't know what to say and
that's because we're all speechless in
the face of mortality
but that doesn't erase the question and
the question begs an answer what's it
all for
well we're trying to figure that out in
our collective religious ideation let's
say
so for example when i look at
christianity i think well at minimum
speaking as a psychologist the figure of
christ is the consequence of a
centuries-long millennial-long
discussion of what constitutes the ideal
human being
now you might ask is it any more than
that that would be a metaphysical
question
but it's certainly at least that and
as that ideal well have you got a better
solution to that problem you know you
think about how it's expressed that that
ideal is expressed in music it's
expressed in art it's expressed in
literature
it's expressed in architecture it's
expressed in dogma spiritual belief and
experience and commitment and faith all
of that
it's a very multi-dimensional conception
and you know you can you can
dispense with it rationally but
well then what you got something better
well no you don't you have something
that looks like a set of arbitrary
axiomatic assumptions that are enforced
by fiat
and and that's that's not it like part
of christianity
let's say was an exploration of what the
idea was there was at least that
exploratory element
i mean i know things degenerate into
insistence but it wasn't
you really think all of that was
insistence by force
i don't think that's a plausible
explanation in the least i mean christ
isn't the sort of character that a
power-hungry maniac would dream up
to exercise arbitrary control over a
docile population it's just
that just doesn't make sense i'm going
to give our ancestors and us more credit
than that you know we were
at least trying to figure out how to be
ideally in the face of our catastrophic
morality
and that question that's not going away
uh heather
i i can't see your facial expressions at
the moment which is deeply frustrating
to me because i suspect i
i can't tell whether there's a lot of
agreement or disagreement
uh with with you on this uh tell me
from an evolutionary biologist
perspective what is the
function of religion do we need it uh
to thrive as a species well i'm going to
punt the first part of that a bit
because it it warrants
um its own dedicated conversation
but um i agree i i agree very much with
what jordan was saying
and um i think it actually indicates
the the problems with modernity in part
are about a deco hearing so
i also agree with the problems with the
new atheists um
atheist is a term that i have used to
describe myself but never new atheist
and that that comes with the full
understanding that religion has adaptive
value
that if it did not we wouldn't find
every single culture
in the history of humanity having had
some form of religion
and what does it mean for us to be
abandoning religion
so quickly well we we can see part of it
you add this to the perfect storm
of why it is that people are grasping
for meaning
because sure any system
that becomes orthodox that becomes the
representation of the sacred
will begin to become corrupt like this
this is the nature of systems
and they will need to be renewed and
there needs to be tension
again you know again one of the concepts
that brett and i explore in in our
forthcoming book there needs to be
tension between
orthodoxy and heterodoxy between the
sacred and the shamanistic
and but you know and without
without this without this system
that people are raised into and they can
say i see that i see the sacred there i
see the holy and maybe i want to go to
it and maybe i want to turn away
people are just unable to even know
where to find meaning and so you know
mind body and soul
i don't know i i don't have a brilliant
grasp of what
all is meant by soul although much of it
isn't what jordan is talking about and
the ineffable
in awe and glory what we feel when we
experience
a piece of music that just moves us
viscerally
but even that you know that word that i
just used at the end
that that is a recognition that they all
tie together
visceral it's body right and so much of
what we're experiencing
now the the deco hearing of not just
society but i think of individuals
is people thinking well i i don't need
any of the stuff of the past i don't
even need to be tied to my own body
i could i can pretend that the thing
that i am from the very beginning
is simply a social assignment no like
this the
all of this is who we are we everything
about our mind and our soul
is embodied as well and imagining
otherwise
is is is wrong so you know i admitted
that i was going to punt the question of
exactly what religion is for
evolutionary up front
um evolutionarily up front and i did
um but i i what i did say clearly was
given that every culture ever known has
had some form of religion
we know there is adaptive value in it
and there is yet to be
a culture that is completely without
religion uh that is succeeding widely
and you know there will be those and
jordan is much better positioned to
speak to this than i am
who knows more history than i am there
will be those who will argue perhaps you
know that the china is an exception but
um but i think that some of what is
passing for
ideology uh for instance there is unto
a new religion you know there something
will fill the vacuum
when you're done because it's growing
faster in china than it did in rome when
it first emerged so
there it is you know that's an
interesting and the suppression is
probably helping it
no doubt yeah it seems that there's an
emergent issue
heather maybe you can tell me what you
think about this if you don't mind so
you know we have to organize ourselves
in relationship to values because we
can't figure out what to pursue unless
we
rank order things because we can't
pursue everything at once and so we have
to rank order things in terms of their
value and their approachability
so then imagine that well out of that we
can abstract something like value as
such right
and then you might say well there's
there's an implicit understanding there
that there are higher and lower values
and the whole value hierarchy is
oriented around
whatever value is and you could say that
the drive to god
is the drive to understand the central
factor that organizes all value
or you could say it's representative the
thing that's at the top of a properly
structured value hierarchy
we all kind of have an intimation of
that i mean everyone i ever
met upgrades themselves for not being
all they could be
well compared to what exactly well
sometimes
the idea that we hold what's that
compared to the ideal that we hold in
our heads
yes well well and it's an odd ideal
because what it does is
whack you when you've deviated from it
and then your conscience tortures you
now
conscience can go astray you know it can
be too severe and it can
it can bring you down so it's not an
unerring guide
but it's an interesting phenomenon
because it sort of operates
independently and
it's not subject to your will exactly
because you know wouldn't we all be able
to
like to be able to just dispense with
the dictates of conscience it's
no you compare yourself to an implicit
ideal
and you torture yourself to the degree
that you deviate
and you might rationalize and lie and
deceive and try to
ignore it and all of those things but
i've never seen that work
and so that's another example i think of
something that's akin to
well that's partly the function of
religion from a from a
social biological perspective it's like
it orients you towards a
collective ideal that's i think that's
actually absolutely right
um if i may tell an anecdote from my
from my deep history
um maybe the first time that i was in
madagascar brett and i were in
madagascar
before i was doing my research there and
we'd been
on a i don't remember the numbers but it
was something like a 43-hour
bus ride that took us only 430
kilometers across the southern half of
madagascar it was excruciating in every
regard
but we met a young man who was on the on
the bus
bus with us who invited us at the at our
end point
to have dinner with his family and it
was at the home
of a of a female judge this was the
early 90s female judge
and her husband whose work line of work
i don't remember
and they were you know solidly middle
class malagasy which is still
there's almost no relationship to what
middle class looks like uh
in the in the weird world in the western
educated industrialized rich democratic
world
um but we were having um a very
interesting meal mostly in french
we spoke almost no malagasy and they
spoke almost no english
um until one of them
is extended families there's like eight
or nine of the malagasy family and brett
and me as young
you know between college and graduate
school at that point so 22
23 something one of them asked us what
our religion was
and we said we didn't have any we didn't
say we're atheists and brett actually
does not will not use that word about
himself
we said we didn't have any and they
recoiled in horror
and they almost kicked us out of the
house
and if we hadn't already had an hour
hour and a half with them establishing
rapport and establishing that we were
decent human beings i think they would
have
and the conversation that continued
forward was them trying
to figure out how we could possibly be
relied on to be moral
if we didn't have religion and i think
having having been forced into that
conversation
by well-meaning malagasy people in my
early 20s really you know
forced into full consciousness how is it
how is it then that if i am not
answering to a god
that i am going to be that
who do i answer to right and you know is
it this sort of
invisible pyramid of values what is it
exactly
and it can't be just you it has to be
you know in in my case i'm very lucky
and you know i had brett and i had each
other then and we still do and so you
know to have someone else
to whom you can always go to and say
tell me if i have done wrong
you tell me if i have done wrong and you
you know you don't hold back
and better if you have a few of those
people
because out you know absent imagining
that someone is up there who can see all
um you need you need more than just your
own honesty no matter how honest you are
francis aren't you glad you and i have
each other no
to put it quite simply but jordan i i
was gonna i was gonna ask
so we are currently experiencing a
pandemic
do you think that's gonna see a
reawakening of religion as we're
confronted
with our own mortality as we're reminded
that actually
we are not these omnipotent beings we
don't have control over mother nature we
can't even control
something as simple as a virus which
religion is the question isn't it yeah
well dr randy thornhill who studied
the relationship between infectious
disease and political belief would
predict
that people will become more
conservative as a consequence of this
and so that's one possibility
you know i think that when you're faced
with a challenge
the issue of what constitutes the ideal
and what constitutes deviation from that
starts to loom
large right and and there's a reason for
that which is
when you're subjected to a catastrophe
one of the logical things to do is to
figure out where you went wrong
so it didn't happen again and to figure
out where
you went wrong is to do something like
what heather described doing with
brett except internally right you
you posit an ideal in your imagination
you make that into
an avatar that avatar becomes your judge
and you have a conversation with it
something like that or maybe that's all
played out at the level of emotion but
that's not optimal you want to be able
to articulate it then you call yourself
on it you say well
maybe if i was a better person this
wouldn't happen to me
and you know sometimes that's not true
sometimes
you just got run over by a bus driven by
a maniac right it's just
you're in the wrong place at the wrong
time and tough luck for you but
by and large if you take account of
those things that you can
take account of the desire to not
reproduce past errors that produced a
catastrophe
is pretty useful uh approach
and and we're very we abstract these
things up to a very very high level you
know
and that's one of the things that's very
peculiar about human beings is
well another thing that god is is the
voice of the omniscient collective
within
and you know you might think we might
object well that's not god it's like
well
these things are not as obvious as they
look i mean
the conscience again calling to you from
within i mean
here's here's part of what that is so
imagine that you're subject to social
pressure of all sorts right
and and you you see you see that social
structure
abstracted as well in literature and
stories and so that's like a
concentrated social structure and you're
just
completely bombarded by that information
all the time
and you build an internal representation
of
the spirit that that characterizes and
it's what
calls you out on your own misbehavior
but that spirit is something that has
aggregated itself
over god only knows how long since the
dawn of consciousness itself
a long long time and so
distinguishing that from something
omniscient that's watching you
that's not so easy and you might say
well that's still not a metaphysical
claim
it's like fair enough but when you
tangle in the fact that consciousness
itself
generated that at least in part and that
you have no idea
whatsoever what consciousness is then
you start to skirt the edges of a
profound metaphysics of
like the omniscient observer pretty
closely
and that those things aren't easily
rationalized away not as far as i can
tell the deeper i've looked into it the
more
peculiar and odd it becomes especially
when you start to think about
consciousness itself so
heather i want to give you the last word
on this because i want to move on to
something a little bit different so is
there anything you'd like to add
uh you know hours worth but let maybe we
move on because that was that was a
great place to end i think
unconsciously all right well listen in
addition to both of you being experts in
your field and really
making a significant contribution to the
sort of abstract discussion there's
something else that we wanted to talk to
you about which i think is very relevant
in
in the current climate and jordan i'm
sure you'll argue there's partly this is
a product of technology
both of you have made a stand at one
point or another
for something that you felt was
important to make a stand about whether
it was principal whether
it was the line being crossed whether it
was an approach you just felt
was not appropriate and i think
increasingly all of us
in our society are confronted with the
fact
that there are certain things that are
being violated on the one hand that
we're
unwilling to see violated and say
nothing
and on the other hand it's very easy at
the same time to descend into the sort
of
social media driven desire to
destroy people with facts and logic
quote unquote and have these
pointless meaningless superficial
trivial battles with each other on the
time
and i was wondering is you two people
who've managed to
be at the very you know in the very
heart of this
argument that is raging in western
society yet conduct yourself with a lot
of dignity
how do we as individuals pick our battle
so that
we can distinguish between making a
stand on something that's really
important
without st without finding that nature
quote though
the abyss is staring so much back into
us that we become the monster that we're
fighting
there there's a lot to say um
and there's not going to be a
one-size-fits-all answer
um definitely pick your battles
and don't spend time waiting in mucking
about battles that you have decided that
you're not going to fight in
you know it used to be before social
media was so ubiquitous
that authors would say you know i i only
read a couple of reviews or i don't read
reviews at all because getting
getting that into my head is not helpful
for my creative process
and i think there's a lot of truth in
that that
we need to be able to hear our critics
certainly you know certainly as a
scientist being
being open to ideas that challenge what
it is that you currently think is true
is absolutely paramount right so
how do you how do you walk that fine
line
where you can be open enough to hear
reasonable challenge from good faith
interlocutors
and not find yourself just you know
pelted with tomatoes
um hurled by you know sometimes real
people but often not even
right so you know the fact that most
much of the
much of the chaos online doesn't even
seem to be organic
actually for me makes it easier to say
you know what off
just just not not doing that because
i'm not turning off people i'm turning
off some combination of people and chaos
and i
i suspect actually um jordan that you
and i and brett uh are effective
in some ways in this realm for similar
reasons
um that even though you were a professor
also for for many many years
it was i i think your clinical
psychology
practice and your relationship with your
patients
that gave you such a deep sense of the
humanity of people and in brett's in my
case it was the particular institution
we were at and the way that we were able
to teach and so it was our relationship
with our students
wherein you see that so many people in
their interactions with other human
beings
actually kind of maybe don't even regard
the person on the other side as a full
human
and you know we we see the
dehumanization
certainly um in you know brexit era and
trump era
and you know just each side picking a
picking
picking a moment a person aside and
accusing
you know fully half of the other fully
half of the population
of not quite being real honestly you
know deplorable or reprehensible
or incompetent or you know whatever it
is and
i think that um
having been face to face with so many
people
you know patients in your case jordan
and students in my case who
i just came to know so well you know
what i say is that
teaching actually made me much less of a
misanthrope than i used to be
i used to have almost no hope for
humanity and
um and people who are superficially
familiar with what happened at evergreen
would be like are you kidding me it was
those yahoo students who you know took
brett out and you were
like no actually the the yahoo students
were indoctrinated by yahoo faculty who
were in charge
there that that was the indoctrinated
faculty and staff who did that
and the cowardly administrators oh
foreign administrators yes yes
but none of our students behave that way
our students were loyal to a person
because we created them we created them
we treated them
like whole human beings and you know
what i used to say at evergreen was my
god the bar
for being an educator at the college
level should be you know something real
you know how to communicate it and you
fundamentally believe in the humanity of
your students and i'm
shocked at how many people fail one or
two or all of those
and so i do think that for those of us
who do have something real to share
do know how to communicate it and do
fundamentally believe in the humanity of
the people on the other side
um that comes across it's clear that
we're real and human and actually
you know fallible but doing our best
and it probably also makes us more
susceptible to
to garbage arguments from bad faith
actors that come our way
and so uh it may be for for me i say you
know what i am willing to just you know
shut the curtain um a lot of the time
because i know that i engage
truly and honestly and really with
people when i know they're actually
people
and i therefore don't have to uh with a
lot of the social media stuff and jordan
how do you manage to keep your head when
all around you are losing this
well it isn't self-evident that i did
[Laughter]
you know i mean first of all battles
pick you much as you pick them
maybe more you know when i made the
first video i made
i was playing around with youtube i put
my lectures on youtube i had a little
bit of experience with tv in
ontario you know so i was dabbling
and i didn't know what youtube was
neither did anybody else
you know i didn't know it was going to
be the world's biggest television
network by an order of magnitude
i thought it was a place for cute cat
videos
it still is to be fair yeah well fair
enough you know
maybe that says something positive about
people too
so but i got swept up and you know
it's in many ways it's been absolutely
devastating
so now i made
i decided a long time ago that i was
going to say what i thought
you know that i was going to try to
orient myself and i think i had
experiences that were similar heather
said something very interesting you know
that she's
much less misanthropic than she might
have been had she not been a teacher
a caring teacher well you know the
spirit that animates our social
institutions is a lot more
in the nature of caring teacher with
deviation that it is
power hungry tyrant i really believe
that
i mean and you have to be
extraordinarily cynical not to see at
least
some of that and so the people i've
known that were
competent in their positions incompetent
institutions were mentors who
encouraged and that's a good
relationship to have with people and
it's the opposite of the arbitrary
expression of power and it's
something you do both of you the mentor
and the mentee
let's say the teacher and the student
you do that in the service of a higher
ideal
and i've never met anyone that i admired
who exploited their students who
considered that a power i mean i've met
professors who
didn't put their graduate students names
on research papers or
were stingy about credit but it's not
like they were
thriving it just doesn't work
so when when do you stay silent well i
you stay silent
until the weight of having to lie is
worse than
the danger of speaking
and i'm not fond of deceptive
silence or outright lies i in my
clinical practice i never
ever ever ever saw
anyone get away with anything
and so that was horrible it's horrible
to think that that's true
it's true you think you got away with it
you just don't know the causal chain
that led to your demise
so you know that plus my understanding
too
that one of the factors that sustained
and generated
totalitarian atrocity was the
willingness of ordinary people to
swallow
things they knew to not be true
that was insisted upon by the
sophisticated observers of totalitarian
states that i found
most influential you swallow enough lies
your state becomes a monster
and so you know i've upgraded myself
continually for
bringing the chaos of the world into my
nice tight tidy little family
and it's been terrible but you know
in my defense i would say i'm trying to
stave off something worse and if you
think
that it can't get worse that just means
you don't know anything
so yeah no it's up to everybody in their
conscience
you know and i think it's a matter of
figuring out what to be afraid of i'm
more afraid of
silence and lies i think there's
more terrifying as am i i mean you know
that i was born in the soviet union and
i've seen
the process of whereby people are having
to make those decisions every day and
actually
that's very much the reason we asked you
for this quite with this question
because
you are both remarkable people in your
own right and you you've
as you say you've suffered terribly both
of you for for what you
took a stand on but also people would
argue you've been rewarded and i would
argue you've had both right you've been
punished
and rewarded at the same time but there
are a lot of people
who maybe they're wrong but they do feel
you know we get the messages every day
i'm sure you get
heaps of messages every day from people
saying look i
you know i hate the fact that my kids
are being indoctrinated at school
but i also want to be able to feed them
and if i lose my job speaking out then
okay great they're not being
indoctrinated anymore maybe they still
are
but i'm also not able to feed them
anymore how do ordinary people
who are not college professors let's say
who may not
become a youtube host or
whatever it is who maybe don't feel that
they want to be a public person as a
result of making some kind of stand
how do they square those two conflicting
desires heather
that was an easy question for you yeah
exactly i'm right we're all trying to
work it out
you're right i'm sure i'm sure that all
of our inboxes um look similar in this
regard
and uh it's heartbreaking and um
i do
when when evergreen was actively blowing
up
i was saying you know i completely
understand why all of the people who are
coming to us privately
to say i see what's going on and
i support you but i can't have your back
publicly
i felt very generous to them then and i
feel less generous to them
now and i actually i'm a little
surprised that that's the direction
it's gone i i what is clear is if there
is
a fever pitch if there is a moment then
you need a critical mass of people to
stand up and you can't stop it
i don't know what the equivalent of that
is when there's not a
precipitating event right because most
of social media is just this slow burn
and i don't i don't know what it would
mean to stand up on mass
there i don't think i don't think there
is any virtual equivalent
um in that slow burn space but when
there is an event and someone
is you know someone's the witch when
someone's a witch and there are 30
percent of people in the organization
who are privately saying oh my god
this is really dangerous and bad and
half of them
are saying to the would be which i can i
know you're not a witch but this i can't
stand up
if that 15 you know and i'm making up
numbers here but you know if some
substantial
fraction substantial minority of people
can actually see what's going on
i think that's actually conservative
estimate and then even
50 of those people said this will not
stand
not in my name no then
then those events can get turned back
and
you know i don't in the particular the
particular case of my story
uh i don't know that the institution was
savable
uh even if 15 of the faculty and staff
had gone public with you know and we
know that at least that number of people
actually saw it was going on and didn't
approve
uh but in some cases systems aren't that
far
gone and they would be savable and it
requires courage
and that wasn't easy for me to feel
back when we were losing two tenured
positions and that was all we knew
uh and it feels easy to it may feel like
it's easy for me to say now with the
hindsight of four years
and um and you know effectively being
funded by
the crowd and it's you know it's it's
both less security and vastly more
security
um most people won't end up in you know
being able to transition in that way nor
will they want to exactly as you said
constantine so
um how how can you encourage people to
stand up in defense of the system that
they are
in you know the functionality of the
institution that they're at
such that it can continue on without
being captured without any more witch
hunts
uh i you know that's that's the piece of
it that i that i don't exactly know
it has to be something like don't lie
you know like if you're being called
upon to lie
or to bury your head in the sand well
where's that gonna end
it's not it's not gonna stop that it
isn't how it works as far as i can tell
so
yeah it has to be something like that
and
i i mean i'm not saying these are easy
decisions i'm certainly not saying that
i made the right decision
i hope that they'd have to cart my
skeleton out of the university of
toronto you know i
liked my job a lot it was it was just
fine
and you know it's been nothing but chaos
and upheaval since then i'm
i mean i have been rewarded but i
haven't been rewarded with security
something like that that's not the right
word exactly
stability maybe yeah well it's high risk
high reward
fine but i would have settled for much
less reward and much less risk
so and i was perfectly happy with that
now i'm not ungrateful for what i've
accrued in the meantime but
but it's not an improvement that's for
sure and i wouldn't lecture people about
you know their moral obligation because
you you've pointed out the problem it's
the proximal cost and the distal
reward right you know you see a system
degenerating
and you're going to say something and
the cost you is going to be bloody high
and that impact is going to be perhaps
not even measurable
but then you run into the problem that
heather just described which is well
if 70 percent of you don't like what's
going on and you don't say anything then
you know where is it going to end and
people have to make
those moral decisions for themselves the
only thing that i know
perhaps is that lying doesn't seem like
a good idea
and being forced to particularly you
know this is where i
took my stand i'm not saying other
things that other people
want me to say it's like up yours you go
and
live the consequences of your speech and
all live the consequences of mind
and i'm not going to live the
consequences of your speech and that's
where my government went too far as far
as i was concerned it's like no
no compelled speech i don't give a damn
what your rationale is
because i don't why should i trust your
rationale
when you're transgressing against
something
so sacred why would i possibly trust
your rationale
there isn't anything more sacred than
the word
i mean unless you want to just dispense
with with with our accrued morality in
its entirety
the one thing we've more or less agreed
on in the
[Music]
you know relatively christian west or
perhaps the judeo-christian west is that
the word is sacred
well if you want to throw that out be my
guest but you're not getting me to throw
that
out so now whether i'm right about that
or not well
probably you know right christ there's
lots of ways i'm not right i can tell
you that but
just lying it's not a good idea and you
say that lying is not a good idea
do we need to redefine the meaning of
courage
in particular when we look at courage
what it used to mean in generations past
going to war
well really you look at a lot of the
courageous people now
they tend to be whistleblowers they tend
to be people who stand out from the
crowd
and say that they don't agree do we need
to redefine what it means to be
courageous i think that's always been
the case i mean if you look at the
prophetic tradition in the old testament
that's just one story after another of
society degenerating towards a
tyrannical state
and a prophetic voice emerging you know
representative of god in some
abstract sense saying be careful
you're deviating from the proper path
and if you don't think they're going to
be consequences
you're just not paying enough attention
well you know how do you distinguish a
false prophet from a true prophet
i don't know maybe the false prophet
tells you what you want to hear
i guess i would just add to that that i
think physical courage and mental
courage are related
that there's a reason that we use one
word for both and that
in the modern world there is far less
opportunity
to manifest physical courage or to know
what it would be
like and you know it's been it's been
much discussed and i
agree with the sense that you know
the lack of war is both beautiful and
um in some ways demasculinizing
for for society um not having that as
even a possibility on the horizon
um and there you know there's plenty of
things that that girls and women do
as well that requires physical courage
but it tends to look different
and in our disembodied behind
screens especially for the last you know
especially during covet era
um just you know a physical lives
without having any sense of what
physical courage might be or what
physical risk might be
of course we're now also more confused
about
mental courage and so you know being
told things like
silence is violence and also speech is
violent so you know
the whole thing the whole thing just
falls apart very quickly
uh before we go to our break and the q a
jordan i just want to come back to you
on this because i'm
i'm not satisfied with the conversation
we've had so far and that's maybe
because there is no answer but i just
feel like
i've had so many conversations with
people where i've said exactly the same
thing to them lying is bad it has
consequences if we carry on down this
path
we will go to a very bad place and we're
already in a very bad place
and the answer is yeah you're just
exaggerating it's just the pendulum
swinging
the other way it will swing back
everything will be fine
and even if it's not well at least i get
to survive today
you go and die i'll survive today what
what does one say to something like that
they might be right you know you just
can't tell can you i mean
let's say the pendulum does swing back
well maybe it swings back because people
stopped it from swinging too far
but then the people who said it's going
to swing back will say well we said it
was going to swing back and look there
right there it went well
that's why you can't in some sense make
your moral determinations as a
consequence even of the analysis of an
outcome
i think that's partly why something like
faith is necessary
so do you have faith in truth well
prove to me that truth is the best path
well i can't
that's not provable and for exactly the
reasons that you just laid out it's a
decision you make at some point
and and you weigh the evidence you stake
your life on
you know you're either incoherent and
all over the place which is its own
catastrophe or you stake your life on
a certain set of principles uh you do
that
you have to do one of those two things
you're either incoherent
or you're coherent if you're coherent
you stake your existence on some
axiomatic principles they're basically
axioms of faith
and you have to decide what those are
and then you live
out the consequences of that and
that's each individual soul's journey
and i i'm not even sure you can convince
people
in some sense i mean you can talk to
people and you can tell them what you
think and you can let them make up their
own mind it's one thing i learned as a
therapist and i watch therapists on tv
all the time they're always telling
their clients what to do
i didn't tell my clients what to do i
didn't know what the hell they should do
i mean they were different people than
me
and i didn't want to take ownership
of their victories or responsibility for
their defeats
you know that's not a good thing and so
i was always trying to help them figure
out what they should do
and you know in so far i think as i've
been successful
in my lecturing capability it's that's
because i'm
doing that for the people i'm talking to
i'm not saying you have to believe this
you know it's
people wrestle with their own conscience
but you know we are
forced to violate your conscience
something's up either your conscience is
malfunctioning or
the thing that's forcing you to violate
it is becoming tyrannical
i don't what are the other options
it's very very true right we are going
to take a very
short advert break now from our sponsors
and what we will do is we're going to
collect all of your questions that you
want to ask jordan and heather
and then when we'll come back we'll be
able to ask as many of your questions as
possible
we won't be able to get through all of
them but we will do our best
to pick the ones that we can we'll see
in a few minutes guys
francis do you like biscuits stupid
question
if you like biscuits as much as him you
have to try
zingy berry bakery they're a small
family-run bakery that make
award-winning sweet cookies and savory
crackers
francis will explain how many awards
they want weren't you francis
the sumptuous cookies are made with
whole grain oats and real butter while
their savory crackers are made with
whole grain oats
and are both wheat and dairy free
they've got a brilliant offer all you
have to do is enter our code which is of
course triggered
on your first order and you'll not only
get 10 off
they'll give you free delivery as well
that's 10 off
and free delivery on your first order
with our code which is triggered go to
zingerberrybakery.co.uk the link is in
the description
it's zingerberrybakery.co.uk and get
your biscuits today
i think i've eaten too many biscuits
never heard him say that before
constantine do you like talented
designers and
tech developers from latin america not
this again
i told you we're not hiring your cousin
a trigonometry of course incredible
interviews
hilarious live streams hard-hitting
satire
plus my handsome jawline whatever takes
away from your hairline but if you do
love trigonometry and you want to
support us
there's only one place to do that and
that's on locals yes
locals is a brilliant platform that has
been incredibly supportive
to our show and other problematic
creators
the great thing about locals is that
it's a community for people who love
trigonometry that's right it's a place
for you to hang out with like-minded
people
share thoughts memes and discuss the
show you can enjoy it for free
but it also gives you the option of
supporting us for
as little as seven dollars a month and
if you want to give more
you can we have incredible rewards for
our higher tier supporters as well
we've got everything from mugs monthly
group calls and one on two chats with me
and kcat get in
join our community by hitting the link
in the description
and the pin comment below see you there
guys
hey everybody welcome back uh we're
gonna bring heather and jordan back
into the conversation now and ask them
some of your questions
uh anton if you can move us around here
we go i apologize to both of you for
those
cringy ads but it's it's it's our brand
um
jordan this is one for you i think but
i'm sure heather you'll have something
to say on this as well rob evans from
australia i think says
it seems to me that the descent of the
west into marxism stroke communism is
inevitable at this point
unfortunately particularly with the
covered pandemic he says being used to
accelerate her
what can we do about this and what how
can we reverse it if we can
well i don't think it's inevitable so
i i think it's it's a it's a
it's a it's not a foregone conclusion
by any stretch of the imagination if you
look at the united states for example
there's there's a fair bit of power on
both sides of the political spectrum and
the battle is raging but it isn't
obvious that one side is one
so and i think the americans have
negotiated their way through worse
crises
than this i mean it isn't obvious to me
that this is worse
than well certainly not worse than
the time that nixon was president that
that period of time say from 66
to about 74. it was pretty
it was much like it is now except worse
i would say so
i'm not hopeless about this i think that
and i do think a lot of this is a
consequence of radical technological
transformation that's
that's a more that's a more unsettling
phenomena in some sense
but but i don't really have any answers
but what to do with that
so francis let me tack on to this a
question and maybe heather you want to
jump on than this because
uh sherry says what do you guys think is
the best way to peacefully
protest against critical race here in
our tax-funded public schools and that's
part of the same conversation i feel
yeah um i guess peacefully protest
brings up brings up images of people in
the streets and i don't think that that
is how crt is going to get disappeared
from the schools
uh i think i think that well
i think we need our schools of ed back
the the
good luck with that yeah and you know
that's a long-term
that's a long-term solution that is the
only one that will stick so
in the moment i imagine that again your
inboxes may also look like mine in this
regard
but i certainly hear from a lot of
parents
and teachers both uh whose kids are
in schools both k-12 and higher ed but
especially k-12
saying this this is a disaster what do
we do
and i guess i would go back it's not an
operational answer
but i would go back to my answer from
before and say
be assured that if you are seeing this
either as a parent or as a teacher or
staff or administrator at some school
that you are affiliated with
you are not the only one and you're not
the only one who's concerned
we i feel certain
and it's impossible to do the numbers
from where i'm sitting but i feel
certain
that it's never just one person and it's
often a significant minority and
sometimes it's actually a majority of
people
an institution who don't like what's
happening
are putting their head down and just
trying to do what they perceive as their
job
or just trying to get their kids to
school because they don't feel like they
can make trouble but they're actually
they're actually dying inside they
really cannot tolerate what is happening
and find each other
figure out some way to find each other
and this is one of the few places where
i would say like i am with you jordan on
the
hyper novel technology being a big part
of the crisis that we're living through
right now and that's the thing that
makes this different from nixon era
right like you know there's
it's just not like that um because
because they didn't have social media
um but one of the things that our
hyper-connected hyper novel
technology allows us to do is
potentially find people
and talk privately and establish
some rapport and figure out what to do
and i think you know for with regard to
in the schools
know that there are many of us out here
who see it and are you know doing what
we can with bigger platforms but
but figure out who it is who else where
you are
can actually see this as well and you
know just start
almost every just and this is not about
crt in schools but like when i just
engage i mean here in portland oregon
which is really the epicenter of
ridiculous in a lot of ways and it's
i love it i love portland i love the
people here and there's just a
tiny minority of yahoos who are just
driving the narrative and driving a lot
of chaos here
and when i talk to a barista
a waitress uh you know the
the person at the front desk at uh
physical therapy you know when i just
talk to any you know
at ups whatever um and just give
any indication when they say something
standard and generic that
i don't actually fit into the standard
generic
model that they're assuming is what you
have to do to do small talk now
almost everyone responds with relief and
wants to have a real conversation
almost everyone i think i think that
actually it's a majority of us
who want to be having a real
conversation and want this to stop i i
think the evidence for that is
pretty clear is that the the extremists
on both sides are a
very small minority i wouldn't
underestimate the utility of writing a
letter
write a letter to the school board at
least you don't even have to send it
at least you get your arguments down and
articulate them that's something
and then maybe once you do that you know
you can write the letter then you can
let it sit for a week and you can think
about it think about it make sure you
got your words right as much as you
possibly can
then maybe send it it's like there's not
much risk there and you know we do have
political structures people aren't
involved in them and
i got involved in political structures
in canada a bit when i was younger and
they're so starving for people's
participation that it's beyond belief
and so you can make an effect locally in
your community or
or in your state or province or
nationally for that matter if you want
to put in the time so
those institutions well that's what we
have and so unless you want to generate
new institutions you
try using those and people think they
won't get listened to but
and sometimes they don't but letters
have more effect than you think
so that's something at least isn't it
and it's not going to expose you to a
tremendous amount of risk
especially if you word it carefully and
you write before you're so angry that
you can't control yourself
in england we love a strongly worded
letter
it's a national pastime it is a national
pastime to find something that mildly
pisses us off and then writing a
strongly worded letter about it yes well
thank god for england so
so the next question is from the rather
charmingly named
towie redback uh it's a dreadful name
but it's a good question
uh do our big brains have a downside
that we overthink things and impose
behavior
contradictory to our nature eg veganism
and gender etc so uh over to you heather
then we'll go to jordan with that one
yeah i mean of course there's a
trade-off there um
and uh just at the most maybe banal
level
they're really expensive to run you know
our our brains are the most expensive
organ in the body to run
and um you know once we started once we
started growing our brains big we needed
more food and then we need to spend more
time getting food and then we needed to
spend time figuring out new technologies
in order to get our food to be more
accessible to us we started cooking for
instance
and you get you you get a sort of
cascade of events that is really hard to
stop
at the point that you start going down
the we're gonna solve this
intellectually
road on the other hand um you know we we
don't tend to solve things with
with brute force we're not we're not the
browniest
ape uh or primate or mammal that's not
what we do so
um you know is it is there a trade-off
yes can we figure out
how to i mean i feel like a broken
record here
um but you know can we return ourselves
to something of an integrated
coherent whole and remember that we are
actually fully embodied beings
with emotion in addition you know fully
embodied
with emotion and not just analysis and
intellect it's not just the logic and
the words
and the you know typing furiously well
hunched over your phone
right it's you know we're here in these
bodies
going out into nature feeling all of our
senses
and having a sense of awe sometimes of
love
of anger of spite even you know all of
these are part of what it is to be human
and it is i think again a failure that
is best described as reductionist to say
that's you know our big brains is what
we are it's the only thing that we are
that's what makes us human
no it's all of this and it's the
integration of all of the parts that
makes us human
and so yeah trade-offs for sure how to
evade the trade-offs
no perfect way but remembering that we
are
more than the sum of our parts and that
we are a holistic whole is
is an approach and jordan what is your
view on this question well you you guys
kind of pointed to it earlier i mean
we're the only creatures that have
discovered our temporal finitude
in an explicit sense there's evidence
from other animals that they have
something akin to grief and maybe grief
itself
there isn't a lot of evidence that they
conceptualize themselves as finite
beings
that's a that's a big difference and it
might be a fatal difference
in some sense i mean if you look at
religious stories like
the story of adam and eve you know when
our eyes were opened we discovered that
we were going to die
and that's the fall essentially and
we've never recovered from that and you
can view the whole bible in some sense
as an attempt to redress
that problem and the story there is
something like well
a sufficiently
noble ethical endeavor might be
sufficient to remove
the sting of death and maybe that's true
so the big brain has a price right we're
s
we're very self-conscious and that
that's great in some sense because we're
aware of who we are
but it's not like it's it's not like
it's not a fall
it's a fall right for for the writers of
of the bible that was the beginning of
history was the dawn of
self-consciousness
and history is in some sense the attempt
to erect
a culture that protects us from our
death
so you know on the upside we live a long
time and
our lives are less brutish you might you
might
claim than those of most animals and so
forth you know
we've gained but not without a price and
it isn't obvious that we can bear the
price
it's not obvious
uh a former guest of the show one
michaela peterson says go
dad in the chat uh so michaela good to
see you again
uh also a few of you surprised to
discover you can ask questions we
mentioned
at the beginning there's a link in the
bottom you can send us a paypal center
super chat and
we'll get to your question if we
possibly can
robin asked a question this is coming
back to the very beginning of our
discussion which is
the breakdown of the family there is a
quite a persuasive argument uh
particularly i think it's more likely to
be on the political right the
the introduction of the welfare state uh
in the united states is what
fueled the breakdown of the family do
either of you have any strong
feelings or thoughts on that issue
well as a conservative in some sense
which i think i became at least in part
because
i was a social scientist and learned
about the law of unintended consequences
is that
you mess with complex functional systems
at your peril and if you think that your
well-meaning intervention is going to
have the positive effect that you think
it will
and only that effect you're blinded by
your own
ignorance of your ignorance it's a
really profound form of ignorance and so
i think there were more factors driving
the breakdown of the family and we
should also point out it's like well
what do you mean by the breakdown of the
family you know
if you lived in the 1900s or the 1800s
the late 1800s let's say the probability
that you were going to lose a parent
before the age of 10 before you were the
age of 10 was
pretty damn high and so the intact
two-parent family
with kids that lived and parents that
lived you know for a substantial amount
of time is
a relatively novel and modern phenomenon
certainly it's a 20th century phenomenon
as far as we can tell
so but jordan i would argue that and
obviously i wouldn't argue with you
about it but uh because you you're
actually an expert on this but
psychologically i would imagine the
impact of losing a parent
uh to a natural cause like disease or
whatever is different to
the experience of feeling that your your
dad let's say walked out on you before
you've even been born that
gets processed and it difficult a lot of
ways you know i
i don't know if you can make a blanket
case that it's worse to have a
father who leaves or one that dies those
are both pretty bad
sure there is less of a sense of of
perhaps the risk of feeling that it's
your fault or that something could have
been done about it arguably
but putting that aside like i think if
you look at the data on the development
of children the evidence that children
who have intact to sex to parent
families
do better is overwhelming
now i don't think we know enough to
specify the fact that it has to be
two sex like you know a male and a
female i suspect that that's the case
for a variety of complex reasons but
that doesn't mean that two people of the
same sex couldn't make a good go of it
it also doesn't mean that single parents
can't make a go of it but on aggregate
it's better to have a mother and a
father and i think the reasons for that
are self-evident actually it's like
well because who are you going to model
your masculinity from if you're
a boy and your femininity from if you're
a girl you'll get echoes of that in the
parent
in the same sex parent but it's not
enough for creatures that are as
developmentally complex as us
and so i it's it's kind of stunning to
me that this is a discussion that we
actually have to have it's like well
and especially when you also consider
something we didn't talk about
relationship to the patriarchal
structure of the
of the nuclear family it's like i don't
know how twisted you have to be to think
that
a man's commitment long-term to monogamy
and child raising over multiple decades
is an expression of his desire for
arbitrary patriarchal power
that's preposterous it's exactly the
opposite
obviously so the fact that we
i can't believe that we're actually
confused about this like
where is the selfish advantage precisely
the selfish advantage the selfish
advantage is
manifested by psychopaths they mate
promiscuously
like mosquitoes and their offspring live
or die
and that's how it is and there's a niche
for that
and that's the arbitrary expression of
power
so like we're so demented about some so
many fundamental things that it just
staggers me
we swallow things that aren't like
incomplete theories they're absolute
preposterous falsehoods
and yet to oppose them means that
there's something wrong with you
ethically and politically
i just can't see how you can make a case
that uh that uh
on aggregate a family without a father
and a mother is better than
or equal to a family that has both how
can that possibly be true
you don't have to make a case you just
have to say that the people who do make
that case are bad people which is what
happens
uh heather do you want to weigh in on
this yeah um
first i'm i'm just delighted i've never
heard a promiscuous mating system
um identified as being like mosquitoes
before jordan so that made me laugh
um the one thing that i would add and i
basically agree with what you've said
here
um is that i think um
i don't see a reason to expect i think
that
you know i agree with what you said
that all else being equal two parents is
better than one
and two parents of opposite sex um is
going to provide
more diverse input to the developing
child
and therefore uh if you have a loving
relationship
between two women or between two men who
are raising children
then uh i you know one thing in
their favor is they had to really really
want those children whereas many
heterosexual parents
end up parents without necessarily
wanting kids right you can happen into
parenthood
um being hetero and you can't if you're
homosexual
but i think it's more important if
you're raising children
as a homosexual couple of either sex to
make sure that you have adults around of
the sex that you are not
so that they are providing some kind of
model for your children of what it is to
be the other
to be the other sex and that's you know
this is not some sort of a
bioessentialist imagining that like all
men are like this and all women are like
this but that
um there are different ways of of doing
things you know even even
down to uh on average women being more
agreeable
than men and you know just seeing what
that looks like
in real time like the more exposure to
the more diverse kinds of people
um you give your children the more
likely they are to be able to wade
through life later on
and especially if you're nate you know
if their natal home
only has men or only has women make sure
you introduce them to some women or men
i can give you an example of that it's a
bit offside but not exactly
girls with brothers are less likely to
suffer sexual assault
right why
well it's hard to say exactly but it's
partly because
they their exposure to men
from an early age allows them to read
the social situations more carefully
more accurately it's something like that
i'm sure i'll get like
lambasted for this but that is a fact
so and is it also known about
the difference between protection what's
that
is it not also the fact that they're
perceived as having protection
you know it works in life even it's yeah
it's a protracted effect so you know
that might be part of it to begin with
but
it seems to be longer lasting than that
it's not something
to claim that you're more likely to deal
with people that you understand more
deeply
deal you know effectively with people
that you understand more more deeply
right how dare you sir yeah well an
extraordinary statement
i do i think look i do think it's a it's
an indication of how confused we are by
how much
change is occurring that all these
things have become
open to question it might also be the
case that
you know that's a consequence of well a
university education that isn't
sufficiently cognizant of the debt that
it owes to to the past
yeah now and i guess i'm actually
picking up
on something that you said earlier with
regard to what's going on at
universities i think
um you know you indicated
that people who are concerned about
their school boards um
could could fill those spots because
people are hungry like the
the political environment is hungry for
people at that level
and i think this is part of what
happened in higher ed
that no one who didn't have to went and
you know pursued governance
you know we're all expected all us
academics are expected to do a certain
amount of governance but
if you were one of the scientists with
big grants you normally got an exemption
or if you you know if you otherwise had
a lot going on
that was how the university basically
paid you
like you don't have to do the governance
so who was left
in all the governance you couldn't do
the research that the
people who were otherwise uninterested
or un
incapable of bringing new ideas
to the university and frankly to some
degree who were driven to bring ideology
in
and so you know we absolutely need
people who are creative and analytical
and logical and compassionate
and actually know something and know how
to communicate it and believe in the
humanity of other people
to be in positions on school boards and
in governance and you know the
the work that doesn't feel like almost
anyone's highest and best use but that
that we need real good people in those
positions
and the next question is by uh another
awful name he's actually a big fan stop
slagging off our audience
his name is i'll fight you naked come on
that's not a good name i don't know if
that says more about him or the channel
anyway but it's a very good question his
question is women
seem more vulnerable to the rock
religion i think because it hijacks the
mama bear circuits
is there any psychological intervention
or an evolutionary perspective
that could be used to at least curtail
this and that's over to you heather
heather and then jordan yeah um
great question i'm actually familiar
with i'll fight you naked as well um
he writes in dark q a as well um
i'm assuming it's a he i with that name
somehow yeah
um yeah uh
it's not a very feminine approach is it
no
um women
both you know to go back to what i was
saying you know right at the beginning
of our time together today
uh women being more likely to engage
through covert competitive
means than men with their overt
competitive means
and also being more likely to be
agreeable which is related but not the
same
thing are
you know and a third thing um more
likely to have their entire world
wrapped up in their social universe
as opposed to men who are more likely to
also say have a shop be tinkering like
have something else going on
all of those things i think make women
more susceptible
to to group think to um
social pressure and to actually
at the point that they have adopted some
new ideology
um or just even just a piece of it to
feeling compelled
to spread it to to others and i don't
i wouldn't actually put it i feel like
mama bear
to the degree that that's that's
something that we can all immediately
grok what that means
um is one of the best and frankly i
don't
think capturable pieces
of of womanhood that you know protection
of your
children and of course fathers do this
too but
protection of your children at all costs
is
actually what i think we need to be to
be finding i was
i was just actually talking with brett
about this last night like we need to
get the mothers to discover what it is
that is being done to the children
and once the mothers stand up once the
mothers stand up and say actually
no you don't get my kids you you do not
get to do that to my kids
that is the thing that will make women
disagreeable and what we need is
disagreeability
we need people to stand against the
crowd enough that then the people who
won't go disagreeable
say oh wait but um there's a lot of
people i like and respect who are going
this way so i don't have to be
disagreeable to go this way
i'm going to follow that new line over
there and it's going to be the one that
is actually
you know honest and honorable and
protective of children
and allows us you know freedom of
expression and
exploration of ideas
yeah agreeable means that you like your
kin but it doesn't necessarily mean that
you're
that fond of perceived predators
yeah right so so that's a weird thing
you know we don't understand
there you think well you love your
family therefore you're a loving person
it's like no wait a minute wait a minute
it's not that simple
you love your family well what do you do
when you perceive a threat to them
you don't love the threat and love your
family at the same time
that's very unlikely and so
agreeableness a very complicated
personality dimension it has
marked advantages and advantages and
disadvantages at
every position along the distribution
you know like disagreeable people are
rather self-centered let's say and they
have a tendency to be
in the extreme they have a tendency to
be anti-social but there's pathologies
associated with extremely high levels of
agreeableness too and we
we don't understand how that'll manifest
itself precisely in the political realm
because this is all new territory in
some sense
so what does female political pathology
look like
well it doesn't exist it's like right
sure no that's wrong you know
we know that the covert kinds of
aggression that
heather was talking about it's a
reputation destruction that that
that characterizes feminine aggression
and if you you know
what's the joke from the simpsons
there's nothing meaner than a roving
pack of 13 year old girls
and you know the boys my daughter used
to comment on this
no and then my friend my son would have
a fight with one of his friends they'd
actually have a fight and then they'd
make up but if the girls got
their knickers in the knot let's say
jesus
all hell would break loose for a long
time and often on social media
so you know is it reasonable to see some
of this reputation destruction culture
as a manifestation of
female political pathology it's like i
don't know but
but i do know that because i've studied
antisocial behavior
and i've been in touch with leading
experts in that area that
that is the most extreme form of female
aggression and so don't and it scales
that's the thing that's interesting
about it
you can't punch someone on twitter much
as you might want to
but you can sure savage their reputation
and so it scales and that's we don't
know what
what to make of that but to turn a blind
eye to it seems to me to be
prematurely foolish
heather i was going to let me just
follow before i go to a question just i
want to
talk a little bit more about this you've
written in the past about toxic
femininity which i think is what
jordan's alluding to a little bit there
do you think you know
this obsession with toxic masculinity
and
toxic do you think that's the useful
frame or do we need to d
d sex this and just go there are some
behaviors that are productive and some
behaviors that are unproductive and we
just need to
try and steer society towards the
productive ones rather than sort of
focusing on which sex it's
more in tune with now i actually
so obviously the the pointing of the
finger at any kind of masculinity and
declaring it toxic
is a disaster and foolish and often
far worse than foolish like actually
kind of diabolical behavior
um and there will be there will be
places i would say
where approaching it without reference
to the sex that tends to engage in a
particular thing will be useful
but there is utility in understanding
that sex roles have been around for
millions of years
and that you know men are more likely to
engage
in competitive interactions overtly in
front of you where you can see it and
when it's over it's over and you know it
and women are more likely to engage in
competitive interactions covertly
behind the scenes behind the people
involved perhaps
and you may not even know that you're
playing and you know those different
dynamics it's not that women can't do
the overt thing and men can't do the
covert thing
but understanding that there's actually
a
sort of evolutionary basis for the types
of hierarchy and competition that men
and women engage in and that they are
different
is i think important you know and i uh
it's not not because we want to
reify what's male and what's female but
because we want to understand so that we
can move
past the regressive parts of it and
those that we can't move past understand
them so that we can actually create some
kind of frankly shared hierarchy so that
we all can all work together
without pretending that you know the
male way of doing things is always wrong
and therefore
uh it's going to be the female way and
you know and we can't even point out
when there's a pathology there as jordan
is pointing out
you know or vice versa you know we need
we need to integrate the best of the
male typical approach and the female
typical approach and i don't know
exactly what that looks like
but pretending that there's no
difference isn't the right way i'm sure
of that
well attempting to integrate them would
be would be a star and
we seem to be quite far off that at the
moment but let me ask this question it's
uh from
important john uh another great name
uh he and his his question really talks
about
uh there's obviously a lot of what you
might call conspiracy theories floating
around at the moment the idea that you
know
covert was created by bill gates and all
this other stuff
uh and uh i know that there are some
conspiracies which have now
increasingly turned out to be actually
true lab leak is something we'll be
talking with bret about on tuesday
but from a psychological perspective
jordan
what is the the appeal of a
conspiratorial view of the world why do
why are people drawn to conspiracies
i think it's often a manifestation
of low agreeableness distrust
it's it's simple and explanatory
so that's helpful we tend to personify
things it's easy to see malevolence and
intent where there's just
ignorance and randomness and because
it's important to identify malevolent
intent we might have a tendency to
over perceive it especially in the out
group
let's say and then but i think there's
additional factors at play right now
like it's not that easy to distinguish
conspiratorial thinking from
just creative thinking right so there's
something happens there's a bunch of
explanations why it might happen
now you might have a cockeyed
conspiratorial version and then you go
talk to your friends and your family and
they
sort of tune you in but let's say it's
kovid and you're isolated
well you know every one of us has got a
proclivity towards our own particular
form of insanity
like we blow out at our weakest point
when we're stressed
and the way that we deal with that is by
banging ourselves up against other
people it's like what do you think of
this
i think that's stupid oh okay well
maybe i'll have to go rethink it well
that's part of what keeps our
conspiratorial thinking
under wraps right we have to share it
with other people and and if they think
it's preposterous then we go back and
rethink it
it's it's distributed cognition in in
the social space
now you can find like-minded people for
your conspiracy instantly
and they're not even real people often
they're disembodied and
and so we also have no idea what that's
doing to
so human social cognitive political
thinking
we don't know and that's another
consequence of this radical
transformation in technology we don't
even know what it does to people to have
to speak to
speak over video instead of in person
what that does to discourse we have no
idea what twitter does to thought
you have to compress your thought into
you know a minimum number of or maximum
number of characters well
does that does that bias you towards the
expression of impulsive aggression
kind of looks like it you know does it
increase the probability that you're
going to speak out
kind of in the privacy of your own
cocoon like you're behind the wheel of
an automobile and shielded
when something irritates you could
easily be these are mass
communication networks with huge effects
and we have no idea about their
what they do to us psychologically and
we'll never figure it out because by the
time we study it they'll have
transformed into something completely
different
so it's it's tough it's a tough one
heather i agree don't assume malevolence
where you can assume ignorance
yeah that's a good that's a good mental
hygiene
approach to conspiratorial thinking it's
probably stupidity
yeah i i agree with that uh and just
this isn't an and also
not following from that but and also and
i know you're having a conversation as
you said with brad on tuesday
um currently
alternative approaches to thinking
through what we are being told
are being branded as conspiracy as a way
to shut down the conversation
right and so this is you know this is
the death of science
this is exactly the same people who are
branding things conspiracy theory
are saying hashtag follow the science
and these aren't people who would
recognize a hypothesis that was
alternative to the only one that they're
allowing us to talk about
if it didn't face so
um you know there's a weaponization of
words
you know again um but specifically
you know as of 5 10 years ago we all
knew that we were most afraid of being
called racist
and now uh it's understood that you
certainly don't want to be called a
conspiracy theorist
but hey remember that every big idea
and probably most of the small ones too
that we now understand to be true
were once promoted by one or a couple of
people
and they were roundly mocked and perhaps
stigmatized and perhaps even
ostracized or even executed for even
saying the thing
and so yes lab leak is a perfect example
and there are more in coveted space
and there are more all the time and what
social media does is it gives the bull
horn
to the to the orthodoxy
to those who are claiming they have no
power at all but actually have the power
to shout down any descent to
the raiding the reigning narrative
you know if you look at the way science
works you think about it this way
well many well-meaning people doing
everything they possibly can to
rein their egos in generate hypotheses
about
why something happens 99 out of 100
times they're wrong
right and now if you're right one
percent of the time and that's
cumulative man you're just your
knowledge is progressing so damn fast
you can't even keep up with it but your
error rate is still 99
and that's with the best method we
possibly have to detect
you know some some facet of the truth in
the political space well
it's much harder so the error rate is
going to be much much
greater and so
and of course everybody's tails and not
because they've been locked down for a
year and a half and
god only knows how insane we are because
of that and what the consequence of
that's going to be
i mean i certainly don't think that the
lockdown is going to result in a net
in net life saving i doubt that very
much
now we'll probably never have the data
and
i can understand that the western world
and the rest of the world for that
matter didn't want to see their medical
system completely swamped
but but
i doubt very much that we save people
we'll see i don't know
i don't know we saved some people at the
cost of others is what you mean
we saved some people in the short term
at the cost of many others in the long
run
and and look those sorts of trade-offs
we make those sorts of trade-offs
because
that immediately evident
catastrophe mortality is a lot more
difficult to deal with psychologically
than
you know a five percent increase in the
rate of alcoholism or something like
that which is basically invisible
i'm not castigating the people who did
this well the people who did that this
were us
so castigate away
and we have time for one last question
we've got a couple actually we started
late remember oh yeah we did start late
so i will leave uh that question i'll
ask it now it's the most important
question of our time it's from alana
uh it's uh and we ask this to all our
guests on the live shows
uh heather and jordan what's your
favorite biscuit and why
biscuit yes cookie cookie cookie
cookie
would you like to take this one first
jordan well at the moment i'm still
mostly eating a carnivore diet so i have
these
meat chips that are everything that
might
vaguely be dessert like so i mean if i
the the unwanted image of of of
strawberry
uh cheesecake with chocolate drizzling
comes to mind but that's not precisely a
cookie
it's just an indication of my state of
deprivation for
having endured this bloody diet for so
long
heather cookie i'm i think it's probably
the most american answer but
a a good chewy chocolate chip cookie is
probably
probably the best still warm from the
oven little crisp on the edges
melty on the inside it's pretty good
you could be a boy
let's stop because jordan looks like
he's about to go off his diet
the way he was vigorously nodding there
listen guys
before we ask you the last question can
i just thank you both
from the bottom of our hearts for
joining us for having this conversation
it's been an
absolute pleasure our audience have have
been so grateful that we've been able to
host it
uh so thank you uh jordan and thank you
heather for for coming on the show it's
been an absolute pleasure and i hope we
can do it again sometime
francis do you want to ask maybe we can
end on a positive should we ask this one
this is from april and it's the question
is
uh april hill how we avoid apathy but
also
not cave into negative thought when
informed of
all that is wrong basically how do you
avoid apathy if you watch trigonometry
um early in the pandemic when brett and
i started live streaming i started
saying at the end
get outside and that that is the thing
that i do
to avoid apathy is as much as
you know i learned from you guys and
jordan like all of you
and many others still
the less time on the screens the better
and
that even holds for just taking in text
i still prefer to read
through you know actual books not on
screens and i and i read a lot
but the more time i'm outside actually
you know pursuing speed in my case
because i just
love going fast outside in nature and
also being totally still
outside in nature and letting nature
come alive around me
that gives a renewed sense of meaning
and purpose
and frankly direction such that i can
come back
inside to this kind of work with with
less apathy and more purpose
jordan well i probably find most of
what's renewing in my relationships with
my family and friends and so
you know to the degree that i'm able to
engage in that
that's almost always to the good so
apathy as such well i find inactivity
much more
um horrifying than activity so
i don't know how to answer the question
in a broader sense because i just can't
stand
not being engaged in something and so
i guess in some sense that question
doesn't come up if it's hopelessness
well you know in some sense things are
hopeless but you move ahead regardless
and that's the nature of life isn't that
you know that in the final analysis in
some sense it's hopeless you're going to
disappear
i don't mean to be pessimistic about
that but it does speak to things we've
already talked about in this
episode and you persevere to the degree
that you're capable of
because that's the alternative is far
worse than that
so then not just for you for everyone
else around you as well
so well i said let's finish on a high we
didn't quite get that but
i sure put the kybosh on that we should
have finished with the biscuit question
i knew it i knew it
uh guys thank you so much for speaking
with us it's been an absolute pleasure
and thank you all for watching uh
with being here with us asking the
questions uh as you know we will be back
on uh tuesday with brett weinstein
talking about lab leak and covert and
many other things
but for now uh let's say again thank you
to jordan peterson thank you to heather
heing
and thank you for watching and we will
see you very soon with another episode
or a raw show all of them go out 7pm uk
time take care
see you soon guys we hope you've enjoyed
this
incredible interview remember to
subscribe and hit the bell button
so that you never miss another fantastic
episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our local